I talked to so many people who are in
comedy in one way or the other and
everybody hones in on it right away
fairly fairly early and that is not your
trajectory you were serious about
uh being a journalist yeah dude I was
you were serious uh serious young man I
wanted to do Sports though let me act
that caveat I knew that I did not carry
my dad's intensity right and and mind
you the year before he died when I was
15 I got my learner's permit so I got to
drive him to all of his speaking
engagements so I just sat and just
watched him just go on stage and just
spit fire for like a year and a half
just churches and community centers and
anything within three hours of
Birmingham I was the driver and hey boy
get off that Nintendo come take me to
Tupelo
okay yeah and I would just sit and just
watch him just destroy with just words
but I knew I couldn't do that
it wasn't until Kenny Maine there's four
people
it's Stuart Scott it's Kenny Maine
it's Ginny most from CNN and this guy
van Earl Wright who at the time was at
CNN Headline News I think he bounced
around to a couple of sports
organizations but those four people were
kind of like the Brain Trust and then an
honorable mention of Fred Hickman R.I.P
but like those people within journalism
were fun and quirky Jenny moose did
offbeat stories she didn't really do
sports right but it was quirky weird
I was like all right that's
interesting
Stewart talks like me then Earl Wright
will do that Sports and then it's like
that was the era
that was the era of when headline news
was a 30-minute repeating broadcast and
the sports section was 90 seconds and
they had a guy and it's crazy to think
about this now but there was a guy at a
time people where in 90 seconds he had
to give you the score
every game of the big four Sports in
this country yeah yeah ape like
talking speeds some Bone Thugs-N-Harmony
but he enunciated every word he added
humor sure you know Jay's down the race
like no time for the score of the game
just who won yeah Yankees fall to the
Clippers Clippers speaking of the late
stuff Lakers Minneapolis
it's crazy to think we now have four
espns you know they're they're that's
the way the culture's changed it used to
be you've got 90 seconds to cover all of
news because there was no ticker right
exactly this idea of constant access to
sports scores was foreign in
1994. yep so you had to watch headline
news so
I go to school
and I'm like okay well I'll just
I'll do journalism this feels right ah
damn it's the family business well I
didn't really plan on that
because I really wanted what I wanted to
be was like a firefighter up until like
my senior year of high school and then
Stuart Scott was the thing that like
finally pushed me over the edge so I get
to school I start doing
journalism classes
part of the requisites for journalism
classes are theater classes for voice
addiction
um
and public speaking you have to take a
public speaking class as well within the
public speaking class you had to take
um
you had to take impromptu speaking that
was like a month of coursework was
impromptu speaking so
during that month of impromptu speaking
the teacher would give you a subject you
go out in the hall for 90 seconds or
three minutes whatever she gave you and
you come back in and give a speech on
that topic as if you were an expert so
it was like improvised TED Talks
and every time I did it I got a laugh
yeah because I didn't know what I was
doing it was clear I didn't know what I
was doing to the point where the teacher
accused me of
trying to you know you're making fun of
this and I'm like I'm not I'm I don't
know why they laugh they just laugh but
I also knew that I liked the fact that
they laughed so I would come back in and
that was the manipulation again well
that's just you know
that training is also improv training in
a way it's the same thing which is go
out there with nothing but with great
confidence make something yeah and so
that was the first hit of True
Performance dope as I like to call it
right we also had to take a creative
writing Course and there were like a
couple different options like essay
writing for whatever reason I chose
screenwriting
so this is all part of Journalism
whatever knowing what I know now oh
you're teaching me how to
create a documentary or write out a
story doc right you know before you
write a script you must think about
where you're going what story are you
trying to tell
so
the script writing class was very
pivotal too
and like the entertainment juices
starting to flow yep and so
I had always been curious about stand-up
comedy I went and watched it a couple
times I went to Florida a m but Florida
state had comedy more frequently and so
I would go over to Florida State and
watch their stand-up shows once a week
or whatever just to see who was gonna
Bobby Lee like was there like like just
guys that are just Titans now but at the
time were just
just on arise Aries Spears like a lot of
a lot of the Mad TV folks some SNL
um
and so at the same time me and my
buddies were stealing jeans from the
mall like that's my
that's just my thing I want it to look
nice
it was not some big conspic you know
what's up about getting arrested
in this country is that
the police automatically assume you
to be doing more
than what they caught you for like the I
like the concept of petty crime does not
exist in our society psyche anymore
it can't just be a kid being a kid it's
just oh no what were you up to what else
are you doing are you dealing with Al
Qaeda that's right I'm sorry what
yeah yeah credit card fraud ring that's
tied to Al Qaeda and Al-Qaeda has been
using credit cards to purchase it hey
man
I took a credit card that wasn't mine I
bought some jeans to impress a girl that
lives up the street from campus
that's what I did okay that's all it was
so yeah this idea of going to prison or
thinking or assuming I was going to
prison that was enough for me to go
now let me try comedy yeah but then but
here's the upside though I got suspended
from school for like almost a year for
what
because you can't be enrolled and commit
felonies they're like you need to go
somewhere and sit your ass down because
I'm working in the campus post office at
the time and so that's where we're
getting the credit cards from so if you
commit the crime only you took the
credit card from campus
so therefore that is the crime that is
going to suspend you on right even if
even if the feds go we're just going to
hit you for credit card as the actual
charge you still did this act on campus
yeah and that is duplicitous is that is
not reflective of a Rat Lab get the
off the campus so
I'm suspended but then I get my
financial aid check I still whatever God
bless the Federal
student loan inefficiency and knowing
what I know now they just sent me the
money so that they could keep hitting my
ass with the interest but
I had a check for eight thousand dollars
and nowhere and nothing to do
for like five months
all right let's go do some open mics
and so that money became the front money
for the beginning of me doing open mics
around the South just like riding the
bus
you know for the most part I was
sleeping the bus day I hoarded the money
because I didn't know when I would get
it you know get any more but
I paid rent off of Golden Corral and the
financial aid money that was the money I
used to start my comedy career
and then I get back in school
and
just Dean's List the rest of
these because at this point my mom my
mom found out like no one knows that I'm
doing this
because
I know my mom's not gonna approve
because you know hey I almost went to
jail but uh I got it figured out Joyce
I'm gonna just
sleep in bus stations
and stand up will be my way trust me
everything's fine College administrator
of 40 years
this is a solid plan
so
one of her students saw me sleeping in
the bus station and snitched on me and
that's how my mom found out I was doing
comedy it's like oh at this point I was
almost
a year into it
and she asked me to stop I refused
and I said well how about this
if I make good grades because my grades
were shaky up until that point like I
was like a two three two four student
I'll go how about this
if I make good grades while I do comedy
you have to shut the up like not
like that but like that was the basic
deal right
if I make good grades you have no say on
anything else that happens in Florida
and she goes cool and then I made Dean's
List and then she bought me a car
so that I wouldn't sleep in a bus
station wouldn't she come see your
comedy for the first time
year three year two did she like it not
bombed it was a coffee shop gig it was
like it's like one of the
one of those rare bombs like a local
bomb
a coffee machine was still going on like
she didn't see me at the Ramada Inn
where I normally do well
she saw like she came and saw an open
mic
because she was in town for some other
yeah and I bombed and that was her
image of me doing comedy for like the
next like three four years
and then when I when I'm I graduated and
I moved back to Birmingham and I started
performing at the stardome which is like
the big time Club there still is
and the stardome again her students and
her co-workers would see me and they
would go to her and go we saw your son
your son is funny
and enough of that and then my mom was
like okay well let me
let me go investigate this stuff I was
gonna say it was such a nice moment
and to those of you listening who
haven't seen Roy's uh set on the White
House correspondence Center I thought
some a moment that gave me chills is
you're very funny you've got really good
jokes you're in control
and then at the end you take a minute
and you talk about why are we all here
this is to raise money and donations for
young correspondents this is to try and
help get responsible young journalists
out there and give them a start you talk
about the uh lack of support for local
news and how important local news is
and you give a shout out to your mom
who's they put a camera on her
um and you can tell
that this is an amazing full circle I
got all these chills you know I'm now to
I also may have been ill
I have a I may have had an infection
and then I got really sick no uh I did
the fish of the steak
both
um no full circle for sure
you know my mom
my mom lives a life of you know she's
just in the shadow she helps people like
I I would argue
it's not even an argument my mom has
done more
for people in the city of Birmingham
than I could ever do just from the
countless students that she's helped get
across the graduation stage and into
their careers who are now prospering
within the city
I it's interesting in that I can be in
public and I can have people come up and
go I love The Daily Show but when I'm in
Birmingham it's people coming up and
telling me stories about my mom yeah man
let me tell you man your old Mama made
sure
and I got pregnant and my mama made yo
mama made sure I didn't drop out and
so
she doesn't hear those stories she
doesn't get told thank you enough in my
opinion for just everything that she's
ever done not just for me but just for
this is thank you for everything sure
just a whole life thing let me just
knock that out real fast